merry Christmas happy New Year I've
missed you all terribly since I've been
gone the most controversial man on the
internet was arrested for sex
trafficking and apparently the more
serious crime of mocking Greta thunberg
a pope and the single most important
Theologian of the last century died a
newly elected Republican Congressman got
caught pretending to be an educated gay
Jewish Banker when none of those things
were true and the head of NASA says that
China might be on the verge of
Conquering the moon we have no time to
waste I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from the yes or no game with my
friend Spencer Clavin which we released
while we were away between Christmas and
New Year is from The Writer's lens who
says this was really good gents really
enjoyed the questions and the reasons
behind the answers I think this game is
perfect for Holiday get-togethers LOL
yes it is many people actually wrote in
because a handful of you lucky people
were able to get the physical copy of
the yes or no game the official patented
Michael Knowles show yes or no game from
the daily wire merch store unfortunately
though the daily wire only ordered about
a thousand of these things so only a
thousand people were able to get the
game before Christmas many of you played
with your families and wrote in and sent
me all sorts of information about it and
said you liked it a lot right now you
can pre-order the yes or no game we've
got the new and improved brand new
edition of the yes or no game we've
ordered I don't know
many more thousands of copies of this
game it is going to sell out though I'm
100 convinced of that so if you want
your own copy of the game make sure you
pre-order right now before they are gone
okay it's a very valuable asset another
very valuable asset gold that's why you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98.98 the current
administration's New Year's goals are
very simple tax spend turn a blind eye
to inflation if this is at odds with
your New Year goals if you're tired of
the government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plans then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
rashes now you can own gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA and precious metals text
Knowles to 98 98.98 to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists with
an A plus rating With Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text Knowles to 98 98.98 and
protect yourself with gold today that is
knoles to 98.98.98
where to begin where to do we begin with
Andrew Tate do we begin with the Pope
do we begin with the Chinese about to
conquer the moon no do you know where I
want to begin
with George Santos I'm not saying it's
the most important story but it's the
one that tickles me the most George
Santos the newly elected Republican
congressman who has been caught telling
some lies
embellishing his resume just a little
bit to the point where we don't know if
anything about this guy's biography is
true or not
George Santos claimed that he is Jewish
that a family name of his is zabrovsky
but that he didn't carry that family
name on because after the second world
war the family wanted to hide that they
were Jewish he claimed that he worked
for Goldman Sachs and not only that he
worked for Goldman Sachs but he actually
went to Anthony scaramucci's salt
conference a financial conference and
criticized Goldman Sachs while he was
working for them he claims that he is a
graduate of Baruch College NYU he
attended Horace Mann school which is
very elite Prep School in New York uh he
claimed he claims that he is gay
and then it turns out maybe none of that
is true and when I say maybe none of
that is true I mean
even the Gay Part might not be true
because it turns out that this guy was
married
to a woman
a less than two weeks before he launched
his First Congressional Campaign in
2020. how this is only coming out now I
don't really know I thought Maggie
Haberman actually had a pretty good
observation on this which is that this
is in many ways a story about the
collapse of local news that that
national news is not paying attention to
every Congressional race and so you only
find out about this stuff after the guys
get elected they should have figured out
that none of this was true he eventually
came to admit that he's not Jewish
but then he said he was Jewish
meaning he you know had a little bit of
Jewish Heritage in his family line and
well he didn't really work for Goldman
Sachs but he kind of worked for a
company that
I don't know how to bank account or
something so you know it's kind of like
working we're going with sex and the
education stuff was just completely made
up I mean there's no record of any of
this stuff
I
I can't go that hard against George
Santos
because
I think look maybe he's got some Jewish
blood back in his family line I don't
know maybe he does maybe there was a
Jewish Milkman somewhere in in Latin
America or wherever the Santos are from
but
whether he's Jewish or not
he's not one one 1024th Native American
right he not he didn't George Santos
hasn't based his entire career on
pretending to be an ethnicity that he is
not unlike say
U.S senator former Democrat presidential
candidate Elizabeth Warren uh George
Santos lied about his education
that's true certainly wouldn't be the
first politician to do it in fact the
sitting Democrat president of the United
States Joe Biden had to drop out of the
1988 presidential race specifically for
lying about his education
what law school did you attend and where
did you place in that class and the
other question is could you quickly I I
think we I think I probably have a much
higher IQ than you do I suspect I went
to law school on a full academic
scholarship the only one in my in my
class I'd have a full academic
scholarship in the first year in law
school I decided I didn't want to be in
law school and ended up in the bottom
two-thirds of my class and then decided
I wanted to stay went back to law school
and in fact ended up in the top half of
my class I won the international moot
Court competition I was the outstanding
student in the political science
department at the end of my year I
graduated with three degrees from
undergraduate school and 165 credits
only need 123 credits and I'd be
delighted to sit down and compare my IQ
to yours if you'd like Frank
none of that was true not one single
thing there was true the only the only
claim that Joe Biden made where he
continues to maintain that it was true
but there's no evidence that it was is
that he won the Mock Trial Competition
but there's no evidence of that he
didn't graduate in the top half of his
class he didn't graduate with three
degrees he wasn't the political science
student of the year he none of that he
didn't have a academic scholarship
a full academic right he was there on
financial aid because he didn't his
family didn't have a lot of money but
none of that was true okay he completely
made that up the guy's the sitting
president so I I can't get all that
angry at George Santos
he's clearly a weird guy he's clearly
not to be trusted he's clearly just a
lying politician like so many of them
are but he doesn't seem to be
especially a lying politician certainly
no more so than Elizabeth Warren and Joe
Biden to me what this story is about is
not about this unbelievable
unprecedented crazy Congressman now
they're all not all of them but many of
them are extremely nuts uh and it's not
about even the collapse of local news
that that plays part of it
this is a story about what confers
prestige in the United States
this is a guy
who probably is not Jewish and who is
pretending to be Jewish
because although we are told that in
America the way to have privilege and
the way to gain Prestige is to be a
white man that isn't actually true
that is why white people regularly
pretend to be members of aggrieved
racial minority groups that's why racial
Dulles all pretends to be black that's
why that white Jewish NYU Professor
pretends to be black that is why George
Santos is pretending to be Jewish he
probably couldn't claim to be black but
he can claim to be a member of a
different racial minority George Santos
may or may not be a gay guy I don't know
he might be sexually attracted to men he
may not be I don't know
but we were told in our society is that
if you're straight you've got it all
going on for you you've got all the
privilege you've got and if you're a gay
guy you're a member of an aggrieved
terrible minority group yeah except it's
the people who can claim membership in
those aggrieved victim groups those are
the people who have the actual privilege
in the United States
I was explaining the story to some
friends and family members of mine and
said wait the guy pretended to be Jewish
hold on you're telling me the guy
embellished the fact that he's gay
you're yes
because those things confer
status
and the the groups that you don't want
to be a part of
the groups that are actually ostracized
in our culture are the straight people
and the white people and the Christians
and and it's exactly the inverse of what
the libs tell us that it is
speaking of prestige
the top G
Andrew Tate has been arrested in Romania
who is Andrew Tate I don't really know I
have watched some videos from the man
because my producers forced me to
listen Michael we want your reaction to
this guy he's taken over the Internet he
became the most Googled man in the world
he's clearly pretty wealthy he claims to
be a trillionaire
I don't think he's really a trillionaire
but he claims to be wealthy
and he's gotten a lot of attention
because he says things that are
sometimes very right-wing
uh he he I don't really think of him as
a conservative or a total right-winger
but he says certain things
they clearly upset the liberal
establishment and so he's been arrested
in Romania for sex trafficking and he
got arrested by the way right after he
got into a Twitter fight with Greta
thunberg
great I I think that was probably the
straw that broke the camel's back you
know forget sex trafficking forget tax
fraud forget whatever they're going to
throw at him you are not allowed to
criticize Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat if you do that you will be
destroyed by our liberal establishment
so he's he's arrested
the prosecutors have alleged that Andrew
Tate and his brother are suspects in an
organized crime ring that sexually
exploited at least six women who were
allegedly recruited housed and forced
into performing porn videos for sale
online
now I know that the
authorities are corrupt
and the system is set up to destroy
anybody who in any way criticizes the
liberal establishment and you can indict
a ham sandwich and all of that but
what was the guy doing in Romania
why did this guy
he lived there okay why did he move to
Romania in recent years
which is kind of a corrupt country
that's known for sex trafficking and all
sorts of Nefarious activities well I get
that the authorities are corrupt and the
system is designed to destroy anybody
who questions a liberal establishment
and you're gonna die to him sandwich but
hasn't the guy admitted on camera many
many times to running and only fans
agency and to being a pimp to just put
it really bluntly hasn't isn't that a
lot of his career is actually bragging
about being a pimp and so he brags about
being a pimp and then he gets arrested
for being a pimp doesn't isn't that
I'm not
I understand that
the The Pimps and the hustlers and the
sex traffickers on the left they don't
get arrested
they they get to continue their criminal
activities for decades and decades
Jeffrey Epstein gets to live on his
Island and even after he is arrested he
gets a sweetheart deal at the Palm Beach
fake prison yeah I know I get I get I'm
not denying that there's some double
standard but
the guy's a pimp right is the guy a pimp
I don't know that's that's kind of what
it seemed like to me now when you want
to get your life in order I would
strongly recommend you check out the
Bible linear podcast with father Mike
Schmitz right now go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you're
somebody who's always wanted to read and
understand the Bible but you're not sure
where to start then check out the Bible
in a year podcast from Ascension the
Bible in a year podcast is currently the
most popular religion podcast in the
United States millions of people have
listened to it and twice it's hit the
number one spot on Apple podcasts in the
Bible in a year father Mike Schmitz
reads the entire Bible in 365 daily
episodes providing helpful commentary
reflection and prayer along the way this
is the only podcast that I regularly
Listen to I absolutely adore this
podcast and have been listening to it
for a little more than a year now
actually because you can take it at your
own pace too what better way to start
the new year you can find the Bible in a
year podcast with father Mike Schmitz
for free in your favorite podcast app or
on YouTube plus you can follow along
with a special reading plan to help you
better understand the story unlike any
other Bible podcast by linear follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story get that
reading plan at ascensionpress.com
Knowles if you want to start reading and
more importantly understanding the Bible
this year go to ascensionpress.com
Knowles to download the reading plan for
free that's ascensionpress.com Knowles
to download the reading plan for free
the story that we're being told about
the Andrew Tate arrest is obviously
silly part of the story was that Andrew
Tate gets into this Twitter fight with
Greta thunberg where he's bragging about
how he's got all these cars and they
spew all of this terrible poison into
the atmosphere and then Greta responded
in this kind of childish way and then
but then when Andrew Tate released a
response to that he had a a takeout
pizza box
and the authorities were able to locate
him by looking at at the address on the
take out pizza box and that was
obviously bogus that was that was
clearly uh a lie because we know that
the authorities have been tracking and
rotate if you if you seriously believe
that Andrew Tate has not been surveilled
by intelligence agencies for the past
many months then I've got a bridge in
Brooklyn to sell you this is the most
talked about guy in the world
he's got this kind of weird Shady
business life he's suddenly making lots
of money obviously the authorities knew
where this guy was and then the pizza
box thing was just the excuse to go in
and get him
uh is it is it fair that they went after
him when they don't prosecute their own
pimps and Hustlers and human traffickers
no but I said this in my very first
video that I did that when I had didn't
know anything about Andrew Tate and they
put the the clips of him in front of me
and they and I said well he's saying
many things that are at least somewhat
true some things that are entirely true
and he's all he's clearly got the right
his heart is almost in the right place
he's trying for something he's
questioning the liberal establishment
he's beginning to Grapple with the fact
that maybe God does exist maybe there is
a moral order but I don't quite
understand it yet but
the guy's a pimp and he's got to stop
pimping okay it's not
it is not based to live your life like a
street hustling degenerate okay it's not
it's not it's not based and conservative
and Trad and all of that to run and only
fans agency it's not based and tried and
conservative to be in your 30s and not
even looking to getting married
or looking to if you're not going to get
married looking to joining the
priesthood or or consecrating your
single Hood just it's but bragging about
how many women you sleep with and
driving your Bugattis around that's not
you play stupid games you're going to
win stupid prizes okay that's all I'm
saying if you go on air and you and you
question the liberal establishment and
you attack the powers that be and then
you brag about committing things that
committing actions that can be
prosecuted don't be surprised when you
get prosecuted okay
just a basic rule of politics
it's true that your enemies if they have
sufficient power can get you on anything
don't give them an opening okay not the
wisest thing to do speaking of weird sex
stuff
terrible story out of Texas
this is a story that we've been tracking
I guess for years at this point the
story of Jeffrey younger you've probably
heard about Jeffrey younger
is this father who is trying to save his
son from being castrated and transd by
his lunatic ex-wife Jeffrey younger he's
in Texas we followed this story pretty
closely and the Texas Supreme Court has
just ruled against
Jeffrey younger preventing the chemical
castration of his son
so uh this means now that younger's
ex-wife
can take their son to California to have
him quote unquote medically transitioned
this mother is a complete Looney Tune
obviously doing very very evil things
she's a pediatrician
Jeff younger has accused this woman of
using their children to help advertise
her inclusive gender affirming practice
so surprise surprise This Woman's job is
to trans the kids and she decides one
day that her son is really a girl and
when when their son first started saying
this Jeff younger pulled out his phone
he said I want to document this for the
future when this becomes an inevitably
illegal matter son
why do you think you're a girl
you're a boy right no
I'm a girl who told you you're a girl
mommy
when did she tell you you were a girl
I love girls
oh I see so mommy told you you're a girl
uh-huh you know it was divorced
um in you know a few years ago
when my um when my child
um hit his third birthday and this
happened during the divorce
his third birthday he started telling me
that he was a girl and
um I immediately I pulled out my video
and videotaped him and asked him why do
you think you're a girl you can see this
video at St james.com it's the first
time I heard about this okay what
happened was all of his authority
figures right his mom his sisters his
older sisters his teacher the policeman
at school the librarian the principals
the lunch lady all of his authority
figures were telling him he was a girl
and I was the only one and me and his
priest were the only one telling him
that he was born and he really just
didn't believe me
absolutely heartbreaking story your
heart breaks for this Dad Jeff younger
your heart breaks obviously for the kid
it's difficult not to be filled with a
righteous anger at this horrible mother
who is castrating her kid
everyone is viewing this as a story
about transgenderism the new gender
ideology or is a story about grooming or
sure it's all of those things
fundamentally this is a story about
divorce
when did all of this start to happen
when did the kid first say that he's a
girl when did the mother first start
moving to mess up his genitals and his
hormones
you heard Jeff younger say it said it
was during the divorce right during the
divorce coincidentally the kid starts to
go kind of crazy
or the mother drives the kid crazy many
such cases that's what happens why is
the kid in this terrible state that he's
in because Jeff younger has no say over
his kids life because they're divorced
and because our current divorce regime
allows crazy mothers to leave whenever
they want to again I don't know the
details of their divorce maybe he
instigated I don't know but
when divorce happens the fathers have
very little say in the raising of their
kids
a lot of times conservatives
when we fight political battles we just
want to treat symptoms we want to treat
the immediate problem that we're looking
at right now and so in this case it's so
clear you want to treat the
transgenderism we got to stop the
transgenderism we got to stop the
grooming of kids yeah that's the
immediate problem but the cause of that
problem the sickness that is driving and
specific especially in this case
is divorce is the breakdown of the
family is the fact that even
conservatives now will not acknowledge
that men and women are different and
they have different roles and they are
complementary to one another
that's what marriage is
marriage as the Bedrock political
institution
is predicated on the fact that men and
women are different and complementary to
one another
but there are many so-called
conservatives today who accept the the
absurd notion of gay marriage and they
do it because they have gay friends and
I don't want to seem mean and they don't
want to seem phobic but put all of that
aside I don't think it's mean or phobic
or anything like that to acknowledge
that marriage can only have one meaning
which is the the Perpetual Union of a
man and a woman for the good of the
spouses and the sake of the generation
and education of children if we are to
accept that men and women are really
different
the second we lose that
the second we stop defending marriage
the second forget about the gay marriage
redefinition thing for a second the
second that we Grant no fault divorce
the second that we grant that marriage
is just I don't know a consensual
temporary reunion of two people well
they titillate one another and then once
The Thrill Is Gone they leave and move
on and children be damned family be
damned the second and we admit that and
many conservatives admit that many
conservatives have no problem with lax
divorce laws many conservatives have no
problem redefining marriage many
conservatives have no problem with
transgenderism as long as you're 18 as
long as you make the decision to chop
off your genitals well if we're going to
grant that then even the conservatives
are not going to admit there's a
difference between men and women and and
then they're certainly not going to
admit that there's a difference in the
roles of men and women they're certainly
not going to admit that men have a
leadership role husbands have a
leadership role within the marriage to
be the head of One's Own household and
so the problem is just going to fester
and we can whine until we're blue in the
face about transgenderism and the child
abuse but you're not going to address
the root causes of of it so then what
are we even talking about
it's a it's a sad story and there are
going to be many many more sad stories
just like this
if we don't get serious about what is
allowing these things to happen okay we
should not be distracted by the the
crazy consequences of the the political
regime that we're living under we got to
get down to the problem when did all
this stuff start cropping up why did it
start cropping up it is a consequence of
the sexual Revolution it's a consequence
of the 1960s and a lot of Republicans
and conservatives are okay with that
it's it's why I can't really totally
defend Andrew Tate because Andrew Tate
loves the sexual Revolution Andrew Tate
is profited he's made millions and
millions of dollars off of the sexual
Revolution okay good I guess you can buy
some more Bugattis
but but you're not going to conserve
anything of our traditional culture
you're not going to stand up for
civilization if you're doing that and
frankly the Republican establishment the
Rhino conservative squishy establishment
they're they're we're basically all
Andrew Tate in this situation we've
traded our patrimony and our
civilization for some fancy Bugattis and
some fun with with loose Women on the
side not great stuff okay not great
stuff at all I don't know about you but
it seemed like the Christmas season came
and went this year they met one minute
you're sitting there around the tree
opening presence the next
it's time to take the tree down although
on that point I got to tell you folks
I know people have taken their their
decorations down it is still Christmas
is not one day Christmas is 12 days
that's why there's a song called The 12
Days of Christmas okay so if you took
your decorations down
put them back up you have three more
days with the holiday season coming to a
close
many of you have already taken advantage
of our 30 percent
off Christmas membership sale but if you
have not done so yet this is your last
chance
get 30 off new daily wire plus annual
memberships and gift memberships when
you go to dailywire.comwles
between what is a woman the greatest lie
ever sold the force of nature that is
Jordan Peterson joining our ranks we
have had a huge 2022 2023 is going to be
even bigger with the launch of our kids
content the Pendragon cycle and so much
more
start the year off right today is your
last chance to get 30 off annual
memberships and gift memberships by
using Code holiday at checkout
head on over to dailywire.com
right now
speaking of transgenderism
the trans bathroom issue is almost
certainly going to be headed to the
Supreme Court
this is a story not a lot of people have
talked about but the the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals just held up in a 7-4
decision that the Saint Johns County
School Board policy barring girls who
identify as boys from using the high
school boys restroom does not violate
the student's constitutional right to
equal protection or Title IX
which is Title IX is the federal civil
rights law that bars discrimination
based on sex which the Supreme Court has
already said covers sexual orientation
and gender identity so they've already
squished into the transgender camp on
that but the 11th
Circuit Court of Appeals decision
differs on the substance from a decision
two years ago by the fourth circuit
which struck down a similar policy in
Virginia so what that means is you've
now got a disagreement among the
circuits and disagreement among the
circuits is when you get a case to go up
to the Supreme Court so it seems very
likely to me that the Supreme Court not
only will be presented with this case
but will
will have to accept this case and so
that means that you will finally get
a clear
National decision on the transgender
bathroom issue which has been brewing
now for what eight or nine years I mean
this has been going on since the Obama
Administration you saw you saw this
first push to let boys into the girls
room and then Obama then there were laws
in North Carolina to stop the boys from
going to the girls room then Obama
couldn't handle that he said nope we're
gonna dog NAB it we're gonna let those
boys go into the girls room and so they
made a federal policy they they used the
Department of Education to try to force
boys into the girls room you you saw a
big political battle for years about
this
now it could possibly be resolved
some people are not going to be happy
about that
you're going to have the extreme
libertarian types say well the
government should have no say over this
come on the government we need to get
big government out of our bathrooms and
if if a school district wants boys to go
into the girls bathrooms why that's the
school district's decision and you do or
the really extreme Libertarians would
say use whatever bathroom you want you
know you're fully autonomous do whatever
you want with your own body
then you're going to see people who are
a little bit more conservative they're
going to say well
I don't want boys in the girls bathroom
but I don't want the federal government
making this decision I want it to be
left to the states
you saw a similar argument with regard
to abortion and marriage by the way
there are some people who believe that
we don't we shouldn't ban abortion
nationally we should just leave it to
the states
that's the kind of Middle Ground
conservative libertarian position or
with marriage well we shouldn't have a
national marriage definition we should
just leave it to the states if
Massachusetts wants to redefine marriage
to effectively abolish what marriage is
that's that's that's their right to do
so and if Texas and Tennessee want to
keep the traditional definition of
marriage well that's their right to do
so too and I just don't think that works
I think on a lot of issues that does
work okay I totally support subsidiarity
I think federalism can be a wonderful
thing and on all sorts of issues maybe
some gun laws maybe even drug laws in
some cases there's all sorts of
all sorts of cases in which the decision
should make them be made at the most
local level possible
but when we get down to really
fundamental stuff like what is a man
what is a woman
I don't think you can leave that up to
the states Antonin Scalia made this
point actually on the question of gay
marriage he said I don't think you can
just leave it up to the States because
what happens then when a married couple
of two men leave Massachusetts and they
move to Tennessee is there marriage
quote unquote going to be recognized or
not you need uncertain really basic
things you need to come to some
conclusions if Society is going to do
anything at all
okay the principle of subsidiarity the
principle of Federalism is that you
always want questions to be answered at
the most local level possible well you
can't answer questions of what is a man
what is a woman what is marriage and
really basic stuff
at the county level here at the township
level
certain things really do have to be
answered
at the tippy top level that's why we
have a federal government that's why we
have
a national capital
so I think I think we can win this
battle
I do think the Supreme Court reads
public opinion surveys I think the the
Supreme Court follows the election
returns I think it's very very clear
that the vast majority of Americans
oppose this transgender nonsense
especially as it pertains to kids
it may I I think so I don't know Neil
Gorsuch has been really kind of squishy
on on this issue but I think we could do
it
Republicans just need to cut out the you
do you kind of clap trap okay or on
McIntyre one of my favorite tweeters
has a line he articulates a
well-established principle and he
articulated said pretty clearly he has
said that the side that wants to win is
always going to defeat the side that
just wants to be left alone
really important principle for politics
the side that wants to win is always
going to defeat the side that just wants
to be left alone we should win this
decision it is absolutely unacceptable
to let boys use the girls bathroom
especially in high schools the daily
wire broke the story that probably
through Virginia to the Republicans in
the election of Glenn Younkin which is
that Loudoun County schools because of
their stupid bathroom policy
allowed boys to go into the girls
bathroom and a girl was raped by a boy
in the girl's bathroom and then the
superintendent of the school covered it
up because it was clear that this policy
enabled this kind of behavior covered it
up move the kid to another school what
happened the kid did the same damn thing
at the other school this is unacceptable
it is it leads to terrible practical
outcomes and it is just
anthropologically absurd that boys can
really be girls and girls can really be
boys
we need to just say no to this and we
need to stand firm on that we have to
have to have the courage to wield the
force of our political order to say no
just say no other governments are doing
it even the Swiss are doing it is there
any nicer country than the Swiss
these guys are so go along to get along
they remain neutral in every single War
and the Swiss government has just
rejected transgender ideology
the Swiss Federal Council just said in
response to two proposals from
Parliament
quote the binary gender model is still
strongly anchored in Swiss Society the
social preconditions for the
introduction of a third gender or for a
general waiver of the gender entry in
the Civil registry currently are not
there
the government has to weigh in on
certain things if even the Swiss can do
it we should be able to do it too
France you know for goodness sakes the
French this was last summer I think
Emmanuel macron leader of France came at
me said
wokism is a an American export
and we don't want it this wokism this
political correctness
this is France this is a pretty lib
Society they say but this woke thing all
this great we don't do that here that's
foreign that's something that the
American society is exporting around the
world and I think he was right about
that
you know the the silver lining in the
storm cloud of all this transgenderism
is I think that it is reminding
Republicans and conservatives who have
gone real squishy and become real
relativists in recent years who have who
have unfortunately
accepted the the worst premises of of
the Enlightenment of end of the last 300
years three four hundred years in
philosophical history to to ultimately
conclude that we really can't really
know anything at all and what is good
and what is bad and what is true most
false and maybe one man's good is
another man's bad and you do you and I
we can't you know all of this silly
nonsense
what the transgender issue I think is
showing Republicans is
there are some absolutes
there are some things that we can know
it's not all just relativism throw your
hands up in the air give everyone
maximal individual autonomy because we
can't really conclude anything at all on
certain things we actually can know okay
like when you start chopping off kids
genitals we know that's bad
and we can say it and we can stand up
for it and we have to stand up for that
which brings me to
speaking of the development of thought
and attacking the tyranny of
subjectivism and and trying to
re-establish absolute truths in a
confused World Pope Benedict Pope
Benedict died
at the ripe old age of 95
um over the Christmas break and Pope
Benedict a Marlboro Man by the way so of
of all the many aspects of his legacy
that are going to be debated in the
coming years and decades I'm just
waiting for Philip Morris to put out a
bargaining campaign because uh Pope
Benedict lived for a very long time and
he famously liked to smoke a cigarette
every now and again but that was the
least important aspect of Pope
Benedict's Legacy uh it is entirely
possible that I would not be Catholic
today if not for Pope Benedict
specifically because Pope Benedict
re-permitted the traditional Latin Mass
after decades and Decades of official
suppression from the Vatican and the
Latin Mass the traditional Latin Mass
which is almost 2000 years old which is
which is about a lot more than just the
use of Latin in the Liturgy but it's
about the entire focus and orientation
of the Liturgy the traditional Latin
Mass everybody is focused at the altar
the priest is facing the altar he's not
facing the people it's oriented toward
God the true object of worship it's it's
much more solemn it's much more reverent
app
Pope Benedict
re-permitted that and it was the Latin
Mass the smells and the bells and the
mystery and the reverence and the
elevation that that
helped me in my in my reversion to the
church but he did so much more than that
he offered the Regensburg address I
think it's probably the most important
speech of the 21st century in which he
attacked the tyranny of subjectivism in
which he attacked this this ridiculous
idea in our modern society that we can't
really know anything at all in which he
in which he I I think completely gutted
the pretenses of scientism from the idea
that we can't really know anything other
than than what exists in the physical
world so so important and and it was
really important that Pope Benedict did
this because this is an aspect of his
legacy that not a lot of people are
talking about but we think of Pope
Benedict as a conservative much more
conservative than the current pope Pope
Francis
but Pope Benedict started out as a
liberal Pope Benedict was one of the
framers of the second Vatican Council
which was
the most liberal event in the history of
of the Catholic Church okay he's one of
the people who he was one of the
theologians who framed the council okay
and and he reminds me a lot actually of
of Wordsworth of the poet William
Wordsworth who
started out as a liberal and became a
conservative
you know all of these Romantic Poets
started out they were all enthralled of
the French Revolution and it was just in
that age to be young it was Bliss and
they were all just so gung-ho about this
liberal Revolution and then most of them
died young but Wordsworth lived to the
age of 80 I believe and he became much
more conservative because he saw the
fruits of that liberal Revolution play
out and I think you can see a similar
path in the life of Pope Benedict Pope
Benedict an absolute genius I mean just
the most brilliant theologian
and prominent Theologian of his age and
and I I think you you see
after the second Vatican Council and
this liberalization within the church
you see Benedict then trying to
constrain that trying to limit that uh
and and then in recent years he's
written about the spirit of the 1960s
and how uh poisonous it was for the
civilization and how it had effects
within the church but it was also caused
in part by the church and by cracks and
Fishers within the church and and it his
legacy will be debated and significant
for decades if not centuries but uh
would it would encourage everybody
Catholic or not maybe just say a prayer
for uh Pope Benedict a very very
important figure and uh one of those who
even if he had been a much more liberal
in his youth has helped to point the way
back
toward a more sensible sane conservative
Christian civilization and that that
that I suspect will be his legacy you
know we've got the voicemail bag coming
up on Friday brought To Us by pure talk
so make sure you get your voice mailbag
questions in very very simple you just
go to the Michael Knowles show page
there over on under the watch section of
the daily wire website click on the
mailbag
you record your voicemail bag on your
phone or on your computer keep it under
a minute please I don't need your whole
life story all right we want to be able
to put it on the air you attach that
audio file mail it in we will be able to
take your questions on Friday
speaking of
Supreme pontiffs
real and imagined
a wonderful way to start the new year
for the first time
in 40 years
Dr fauci
is no longer in the government
Dr fauci
is gone
we just breathe a sigh of relief his
last day of public service was December
30th
he uh recently sat down with the New
York Times for an interview
so here he goes this is after half a
century fauci prepares for Life After
government and I love that this is the
first line of the article
the walls in Dr Anthony s fauci's home
office are adorned with portraits of him
drawn and painted by some of his many
fans the most striking one is by the
singer Joan Baez the two of them he said
have become pretty good friends over the
years
tells you everything you need to know
about Anthony facci the walls of his
home office
are covered in pictures of himself
this is quite a stark contrast with the
late Pope Benedict
for many modern people Dr fauci is the
Pope
and certainly for the two and a half
years of the height of the covet
hysteria Dr fauci had more not only
scientific but Spiritual Authority than
anybody else on Earth he really he
really was
the secular Pope okay and you see this
huge contrast Pope Benedict
one of the most humble men in public
life
ever certainly of our lifetimes
Dr fauci one of the most prideful men
ever he said I am science I am the
representative of science okay whatever
I decree is the truth Dr bouchi never
admitted he was wrong about anything
even when he got caught in the lies even
when he admitted to lies he he didn't
want to acknowledge that there was
anything wrong about that
and it is no coincidence no mere
coincidence at least that
Dr fauci's life's work has been about
just
inculcating this dictatorship of
scientism that if something can't be
looked at under a microscope it's not
real it has no Authority Dr fauci says
because I am the scientist I don't have
political views
he actually said this I'm slightly
paraphrasing I don't have political
views that I make public I just talk
about the science I just talk about what
works
but what does that mean if you're if
you're advocating for political
lockdowns
if you're advocating for Mass
vaccinations and even coerced
vaccinations in some cases
that involves all sorts of philosophical
epistemological ontological theological
premises that he's not acknowledging
why does this man have the right
to force his opinion on everybody else
why does this man think that his
scientific observations
therefore lead to the conclusion that we
need to lock down the economy for
instance
all of these philosophical premises
that he says well you just have to
accept all of them because I am the
science he doesn't even acknowledge that
they exist that is scientism okay so
much of Benedict's work
was opposed to that was about knocking
down scientism Benedict actually I guess
this was right when he became Pope
though it's only only been released now
he released a spiritual Testament it's
worth reading the whole thing
but here's the final part
Benedict wrote stand firm in the faith
do not be confused often it seems as if
science on the one hand the Natural
Sciences on the other historical
research especially the exegesis of the
Holy scriptures has irrefutable insights
to offer that are contrary to the
Catholic faith so what he's saying is
present present day science where people
are studying chemicals today and
historical science where you look to the
past and you look at aspects of I don't
know the theory of evolution or geology
or whatever but it's all about science
he says I have witnessed
from times long past the changes in
Natural Science
and have seen how apparent certainties
against the faith vanished proving
themselves not to be science but
philosophical interpretations only
apparently belonging to science just as
moreover it is in dialogue with the
Natural Sciences that faith has learned
to understand the limits of the scope of
its affirmations and thus its own
specificity for 60 years now I have
accompanied the path of theology
especially biblical studies and have
seen seemingly unshakable Theses
collapse with the changing Generations
which turned out to be mere hypotheses
the liberal generation the
existentialist generation the Marxist
generation I have seen and see how out
of the tangle of hypotheses the
reasonableness of faith has emerged and
is emerging Anew Jesus Christ is truly
the way the truth and the life and the
church in all her shortcomings is truly
his body
absolutely beautiful
eloquent as ever
Benedict not only a brilliant thinker
but also a very good writer often those
two things go hand in hand
whose Legacy is going to look better
10 years from now
50 years from now
200 years from now
Dr fauci
or Pope Benedict
we know we can already look at it with
the distance of five days fauci's Legacy
looks preposterous from the claims that
he made
based on his authority of science
have collapsed
going back to the 80s the guy bungled
AIDS he bungled everything and
especially covet
Pope Benedict
in his humility
in in fettering his reason his very high
capacity for reason two
substantial things to Eternal truths
to the weight of the magisterium to the
Gospel of Jesus Christ to things that
have endured and will endure forever
Benedict's Legacy
will come out much stronger that's what
he's saying he's saying I've seen it you
hear this all the time when people say
well the science is clear about global
warming if science is so clear we've got
to upend the whole society we need a
great reset of society completely up in
the economy in the political order
because the science is so clear
say well but this the science that is so
clear today about global warming
was so clear 50 years ago about global
cooling and that's not just a talking
point from the right that wants to deny
climate change this was written about
not only in popular magazines and
newspapers but in scientific journals
from some of the most esteemed
scientists in the world I write about
this at like there's a chapter about
this in my book speechless controlling
words controlling mines available now
for order
I'm glad we still have the Bell even in
the new year
Benedict is saying I've seen this happen
and he can see it happen
in part because he just lived to be a a
very ripe old age okay 95 years old
and you see this throughout history
what's that old line they say if you're
not a liberal by the time you're 17 you
have no heart if you're not a
conservative by the time you're 30 you
have no brain okay people tend to become
more conservative over time
and especially when that conservatism is
grounded in something real not the
shallow
non-theistic conservatism of you know go
out and make money and you do you and
Rob some Bugattis but real deep
conservatives where we're conserving
human nature where we're conserving the
very best in our society and
civilization that is going to give you a
much stronger perspective as well
speaking of scientific certainties
NASA is warning that China is about to
conquer the Moon
we don't have time to get to it today
that'll be that'll be my little teaser
for tomorrow get ready for the Chinese
to conquer the moon We Will We Will
delve that scientific certainty uh
tomorrow we don't have time because
right now we're going to speak with
hermit Dylan who is challenging RNC
chairman Ronald McDaniel for the
leadership of the Republican National
Committee this is a we've been a little
bit philosophical today we've been a
little bit far afield because you know
look it's Christmas time all right we're
still we're still thinking about eternal
things but we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty of politics right now
that's on the member block you do not
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]